[Music]
the commercial is super creative to be
in a super bowl commercial is special
but the people that do came up with a
concept
that guarantees it will be talked about
[Music]
it is an honor for the super bowl to
have kiss
on the super bowl it takes two hours to
do this
fluff muff lift separate point in your
general direction anything worth doing
is worth overdoing
it's a little bit of pressure because
they have genius commercials so we have
to make sure our commercial is really
cool
the year 2010 e.t caught up with beyonce
and hair and makeup prepping to take a
wild ride in a robotic arm
i think i'm going to be
flying around in a harness all day which
is fun
just one year before valerie bertinelli
showed off her nearly 50 pound weight
loss and told us her go-to super bowl
snack
oh my goodness every year we we make
gumbo are you ready bites start popping
jessica simpson shot ads three different
years once in skinny jeans
oh my gosh i can't say it a pullable
poppable pizza
pull i mean peter piper
once super glam and once in boots made
for walking with co-star miss piggy i've
got green peppers just for you kermie
[Music]
miss piggy's in a cute little juicy suit
and has bling bling so it's very fun
celebs like seth rogen and amy schumer
can earn up to two million dollars per
ad brad pitt earned a reported 4 million
hey can you come pick me up
you know being a good actor and actress
oh yeah baby i'm an actress now
you are
i don't really know how to say this
other than to just say it you're amazing
some of this might have to be cut out
because it probably won't be able to air
during the super bowl let's just say it
gets a little sweaty and slippery
but will ferrell says he made no money
for his beer ad he just wanted to be in
a crazy fun commercial
are you doing cringe face right now
no
what's the magic word
sexiest man alive i think the biggest
shocker
is that we're actually gonna be driving
it
people do these commercials and they
don't use they don't eat what they're
eating in the commercials none of those
girls are eating those burgers but one
of our faves let's throw it back to 1997
and a baby face tiger woods paired with
jerry maguire's jonathan lipnicki on the
set of a nike commercial how did you
like super bowl commercials
um i didn't like them personally well
i've always been taught by my parents
never to give any thought to anyone's
expectations about yourselves
and that's all i focus on that's all i
care about what my goals my aspirations
are
and i'm gonna try to live up to those
of course the late betty white provided
one of the most memorable spots you're
playing like betty white out there
that's not what your girlfriend said i
didn't know it was going to air on the
super bowl and then it aired on the
first commercial of the super bowl
and it was a delightful surprise
just last week ashton kutcher gave us
life posting this video of wife mila
kunis breaking dry january the couple
shot this ad in 2021 the perk of working
together
but i cut you at the counter it wasn't
me
it's like working with your best friend
it can go one way or the other right and
we are incredibly co-dependent on each
other so this just feeds into our
co-dependency
[Music]